[Musique] étrangère [
Musique]
accède au réseau Wi-Fi domestique
uniquement si l'utilisateur active le Wi-Fi. Je suis
désolé, je ne comprends peut-être pas cela, donc si
j'ai une application Stick Talk sur mon téléphone et mon
téléphone  est sur mon réseau Wi-Fi domestique,
coche l'accès à ce réseau,
il devra accéder au réseau pour
se connecter à Internet si
telle est la question,
est-il possible alors qu'il puisse accéder à
d'autres appareils sur ce réseau Wi-Fi domestique,
membre du Congrès  que nous ne faisons rien
qui dépasse les normes de l'industrie.
Je crois que la réponse à votre question
est non. Je ne pense pas que la propriété soit le
problème ici, avec beaucoup de respect.
Les entreprises sociales américaines n'ont pas un
bon bilan en matière de confidentialité des données.  et
la sécurité des utilisateurs, je veux dire, regardez Facebook et
Cambridge Analytica, juste un exemple
pouvez-vous me dire maintenant pouvez-vous dire
avec une certitude à cent pour cent que
Tick Tock n'utilise pas l'appareil photo du téléphone
pour déterminer
si le contenu qui provoque une
dilatation de la pupille doit être amplifié  par l'
algorithme, pouvez-vous me dire que nous ne
collectons pas de données corporelles, faciales ou vocales pour
identifier nos utilisateurs,
nous ne le faisons pas
[Musique]
les seules données faciales que vous obtiendrez et que
nous collectons sont lorsque vous utilisez les filtres
sur lesquels vous portez les mêmes lunettes de soleil  ton visage nous
devons savoir où sont tes yeux pourquoi as-
tu besoin de savoir ce que sont les yeux si
tu ne vois pas s'ils sont dilatés
[Musique]
merci